Hello everybody. Hope that you are good.
This video has been requested in the
comment section under my last videos uh
for quite a long time. So here it is. If
you have any other idea, please let me
know cuz I'm listening. We're going to
analyze Ethereum. It's going to be my
Ethereum projection or the path for
Ethereum in my opinion of course uh for
the next one to two months. So it's
going to be quite like short midterm.
Okay. Mostly focused on this first
quarter of of 2026. But for that we need
to analyze Bitcoin first because if
Bitcoin moves down, Ethereum, Solana,
doesn't matter which altcoin is also
going to tend to go down. Okay, Bitcoin
is the king and the market follows
Bitcoin. So it's important to know what
Bitcoin is going to do. And in my
opinion, uh that's the case. I think
it's going to go lightly down in the
daily time frame towards this long week
here. The minimum target I have is the
50% level of this long week, which is at
83K. And usually my targets for the
quickfill strategy are either the 50% or
the 100% levels. Okay. So that would be
either 83k or 80k. You know that area is
what I'm looking at. That is basically
this red box marked here in the chart.
All right. And my original projection
was that Bitcoin was going to go up from
the mid-range towards the local
resistance where it could get rejected.
That's basically what it's happened. And
if you've noticed right now, it's been
under the week, the daily 50 MA for the
last five days and is testing it as
resistance and not being able to break
through, which is obviously a bad sign.
Bitcoin needs to go back above the daily
50 MA soon. Otherwise, it's telling you
that rejection could potentially be in
play towards the local support. And if
it loses that level, probably what I'm
aiming at is this area here around the
50% level of this long week. Okay? at
least. So careful with that. I always
keep a door open for the possibility of
a liquidity run first and that would be
basically a false move to the upside
before dropping down towards this level
which in my opinion would be the real
move and a liquidity run. I'm going to
tell you why it's important to always
consider why it could be in play and
it's been proved for example with fit
FTX and Anamea Research. They went to
court and they lost it. found guilty for
manipulation and it's something that is
still happening in the market. Many
exchanges have their own market maker
company. So at the end is the same
company you know and and that happens in
many exchanges. I'm not going to say
names but it happens in a lot of
exchanges and and probably most of them
and somehow they must be interconnected
between them because price moves in the
same way in across all exchanges and
basically what it happens and it's a
problem because this is still not fully
regulated. So it is still happening a
lot. It's basically that the exchange
owns a market maker company. So at the
end is the same company and when that
happens is very dangerous because you
have to think that when we traders when
we are opening and closing trades in an
exchange the exchange have a lot of
information. They know our entry points
with the limit orders. They know our
liquidation levels. They know our take
profits. They know our stop- losses.
Okay? They have all the info because we
put into the system. And it's very
dangerous when the market maker can
access to all of that information
because it's the same company as the
exchange. Okay? So the exchange can pass
that information to the market maker and
the market maker, you know, if they know
where the level with the most
liquidation is or with the most stop-
losses and they have all the liquidity
to be able to move price into that
direction to hit that area. Of course,
they're going to do it because the
exchange makes money when you lose. It's
a fact. The change makes money in two
ways. It makes money in fees because
when we trade we're generating earning
um trading fees and obviously that's
money for them and the biggest fee for
them are the liquidations because when
you get liquidated where do you think
all the money goes to? Also just think
that is the 100% of your current
position. It's not like the stop loss
that it's a percentage that you are
risking. No no the liquidation is the
whole position. So it's the biggest fee
that the market maker and the exchange
they can earn. Okay. So you can
understand how that's a conflict of
interest and how dangerous it can be for
traders. And that's why I always try to
keep my eyes open for a potential
liquidity run. Okay? So be careful that
this doesn't happen. And I'm projecting
that it's possible to see one towards
the weekly 50 MA which would be a high
time frame resistance. Okay? That's
around 97K 96K. So careful with that.
It's still possible. It was still
happening. But overall doesn't matter if
price drops from here from the local
resistance where we already got
rejection or if price goes up and does
this liquidity run first. Doesn't matter
what happens from either of those two
levels. I'm expecting a retrace back to
the range lows back to this long week.
Okay? Again, it's my opinion. I might be
completely wrong. Time will tell. Um,
I'm not telling you to go with my
analysis because that's uh it could be
completely incorrect. I'm only telling
you my opinion, okay? And my analysis.
So with this information that or this
Bitcoin analysis that I have that I'm
projecting Bitcoin to sooner or later
drop back down towards 83K at least if
we go to Ethereum. Okay, we can use the
information to try to understand what
could potentially Ethereum do according
to my opinion. Okay, so basically I drew
here a couple of high time frame uh
supports and resistances. You can
clearly see that this high time frame
support comes from here. Okay, 2,400 was
a very strong support. Yes, we saw
deviation. Then back to test support.
That will be our entry point. Price goes
up. Okay, so that's a high time frame
support. Same as this previous
resistance here also was. Okay, that was
a support then here became resistance
and now recently became also support. So
those two levels 2,700 let's say and
2,400
those are going to be our high time
frame supports. Now in in exchange
for resistances we have obviously this
level here 4,750
which is very far away. In fact we could
even remove this from the chart because
it's really far away isn't it? And this
local resistance at 3,400.
You can clearly see that it's been
support
resistance resistance. All right. And
you ultimately the thing that I wanted
to mention is this. If you are talking
about liquidity and liquidations are
stop- losses, you need to understand
that when you see a liquidity trend line
as I call them and many others call
them. These liquidity trend lines that
are perfect. the price, you know, goes
down, tested a support, goes up, goes
down, support, up, down, support, up,
down. Where do you think that? What do
you think is happening here? Well, I can
tell you I can tell you that at this
level, there are going to be a lot of
buy orders because people are expecting
that it's going to happen the same as
here that this train line acts as
support. Okay, so we know for a fact
that at this level there are going to be
some buy orders, but also we know that
there are going to be a lot of stop
losses below this level. And you can see
how every time that it goes higher, this
area gets bigger and bigger and bigger
and bigger exponentially. And it means
that this area there are more stop-
losses than there were here. Can you see
the difference? because there are more
times that ill trader traders to come
into here to open a long position and
they're going to be placing their stop
losses here. So you have to understand
that eventually and this is what usually
happens price comes down and doesn't
bounce from here but continues going
down. Okay, hitting all the stop-
losses.
So be careful with that. That's what I
see for Ethereum. I see that there is a
big risk that Ethereum comes down to
basically hit all these stop- losses.
Okay, careful with that. At least I
would say that is going to come back
down to the high time frame support
2,700.
Okay, uh that's not a board statement
because that's a 14 13 14% drop. Okay.
And that would be obviously
only
possible to happen if Bitcoin drops as I
think towards 83k. Obviously Bitcoin if
Bitcoin goes up from here, Ethereum will
do the same. Okay? So you have to
understand that those two analysis are
correlated.
Ethereum won't do that if Bitcoin
doesn't do it first. All right? So
basically for Ethereum, that's what I
see. I see that there is a high risk for
Ethereum to drop back to the high time
frame support of 2,600 2 sorry 2,700.
Now from this level the same as Bitcoin
we're are going to analyze the given uh
price action at the moment and the and
the context that we'll have at that time
and from there we'll either analyze that
you know it could bounce from there or
if it loses this level it goes down to
the next high time frame support at
2,400. But again that is not of my
concern. I'm not interested on that yet.
I'm only looking at Ethereum potentially
trading back to 2,700
and Bitcoin to 83K. All right, so that's
all that I see on Ethereum. Shortterm, I
see that it could potentially go down
and then in the midterm
I do see either a bounce from this time
frame support at 2,700 or 2,400. There
is not much difference between both of
them, maybe 89%. and in high time frame
I'm bullish on 2026.
I've explained my arguments and my
reasons on the video that is called
Bitcoin 2026 price prediction. Okay, so
you can go and watch it. Those are my
arguments for 2026 to be bullish in a
crypto market. And obviously I do see
Ethereum bouncing from here or from here
towards the highs. Okay, potentially
even new highs. So that's what I think
in terms of Ethereum and Bitcoin. Happy
to being useful if if I'll only be if
this is correct. So let's see. Either
way, don't trade based on my analysis.
Only use it as confluence. Same with any
other analyst because we all could be
wrong. Okay, so thank you so much for
watching and I'll see you soon.